it's like it's something that I've
always known that we become what we
think about and if you change the way
you think about things you change the
world that you live in this is about
changing your thoughts
and then your life will change change
your thoughts change your life he said I
decided that sooner or later I would
have to get over this or it would kill
me and he said I just pick Sooner
attitude is everything so pick a good
one I can attract anything I want into
my life you know I am in charge of my
life I you know I can create health and
happiness and and being positive I just
remind myself of that over and over and
over again until it just becomes a way
of being all things are possible
literally means all things are possible
so whatever whatever it is you'd like to
attract into your life whatever you'd
like to accomplish whatever you'd like
to do in your life if you start from a
spiritual place a place of all things
are possible if I return you know and
get to that place and then I begin to
visualize it and I begin to use my
imagination because everything that we
see around us everything in this world
was once imagined so your imagination is
the greatest gift that you've been given
and you can put anything in there no one
can tell you what can be there or what
can't be there you have to learn to live
from the end whatever you have placed
into your imagination you have to act as
if it already already were your reality
independent of what anything or anyone
else says we want to be very careful
because there's always people out there
who are willing to send you messages
about how terrible something is going to
be assuming the feeling of the wish
fulfilled you must be able to feel it
because every time that you feel
something within your body you give a
instruction to your subconscious mind
and your subconscious mind is the part
of you where you do all of your living
you want to re-do your subconscious mind
so by placing into your imagination what
you want and assuming the feeling of
that wish is already fulfilled you go
through your life feeling that when
enough of us do that we will we will
transform this planet and that's just
what my mission is is just to teach
people that you are love you are Divine
put that into your imagination I am I am
well I am happy I am content I am
fulfilled even if your senses tell you
that you're depressed because for me
manifesting is not about
attracting what you want
manifesting is an awareness and an
understanding that you attract what you
are all of us have within us this
amazing capacity to manifest and attract
anything that we want into our life you
say I will attract into my life what I
am not what I want and I am capable of
attracting all things that that the
source is capable of attracting you get
what you are rather than what you want
everything turned around because I got
the rage out of me because in order to
attract the elements that are going to
bring you the ability to manifest into
your life what you want we do not
manifest what we want that comes from a
place of missing we manifest what we are
the Angels who will guide you throughout
your life will only be there for you
when they recognize themselves in you
and they cannot recognize themselves and
you and guide you when you are filled
with hatred anger judgment condemnation
bitterness fear anxiety stress you have
to let all of that go and be loved be in
this place a perfect
Divine love love for everything and
everyone on our planet that's
self-actualization at work and the
principles for bringing this about into
your life are the last five chapters of
which is fulfilled but basically what it
says is the greatest gift that you've
ever been given
the gift of your imagination
your imagination is yours
to be able to do anything you want with
you can place any thought in there with
the awareness of I am
so what I encourage you to do in terms
of manifesting before I get into the
principles is to take out a piece of
paper sometime when you're at home it
sounds like a silly thing to do but I
want you to do it I want you to right at
the top of that page the word that
t-h-a-t that
okay and under that heading whatever it
is that you would like to attract or
manifest into your life
I would like you to just write that down
all right so if it's a job that you want
if it's a relationship that you want if
it's a a healing that you want if it's a
abundance that you want to attract into
your life whatever it is just place it
underneath that and come to a place in
your life
where it is spoken about in The Book of
Romans in the New Testament
he calls those things which do not exist
as though they did
you must be able to get to this place in
your life where you don't use the
evidence of your senses what your eyes
tell you what your ears tell you
what your stomach tells you
[Music]
what you see written down what the
internet tells you
you want to be able to be in a place
where you are living from the end as if
what you would like to manifest is
already there to make a present a future
dream a present fact you must assume the
feeling of that wish as already being
fulfilled so I want to talk to you about
walking down another Street this other
street is a street in which you have an
awareness not only do you have a
physical body but you have come to
believe
that this physical body is who you are
and that you have locked yourself into
these five senses
and decided that whatever evidence they
provide for you
is how you identify and Define your
reality and I think the most significant
thing about it is that you you begin to
realize that uh that who I am is not a
human being here having a spiritual
experience but it's really the reverse
that who I am is a spiritual being an
infinite spiritual invisible being
having a temporary Human Experience and
the key to living an inspired life is to
always come from that place we are all
infinite beings
in a temporary Human Experience
to be able to return
to that place from which you came and
live your life from the spiritual
perspective and become a god-realized
being letting go and letting God
allowing yourself to trust in your
nature allowing yourself to no longer
believe that everything has to be
controlled by me and that other people
no longer have to be in control of me as
well begin to trust instruct just like
you did for the first nine months
you trust it your nose showed up so why
not wander through your life and have
this wonderful peaceful knowing that
it's all fine relax let go lighten up
practice non-interference see God in
nature find your find your true self in
the in in the joy of of the miraculous
the number one regret that people have
people who were dying who knew that they
were crossing over and making their
transition the top regret was I wish I'd
had the courage to live the life that I
knew I was destined to live there are
only two emotions there's fear and
there's love and everything that is fear
cannot be love and everything that is
love cannot be fear so you have to ask
yourself at any moment in your life am I
in love or am I in fear the natural
tendency of Life Is Love Peace Beauty
Harmony and opulence it's one of the
most freeing peaceful uh experiences to
know that you're not here to accomplish
anything you're not here to be better
than anybody else you're not here to win
all you have to do is just love yourself
I mean truly love how magnificent you
are you're you're going against your
down nature your true nature is not
Revenge your true nature is not hatred
you came from Love and you have to stay
in that state and once you once you
learn that once you get there once you
like having that demonstrated could
change your life just that moment can
take forever for the four cardinal
virtues reverence for all of life
honesty kindness service that's a
spiritual life you're a vessel you're a
container and and the more Divinity that
you allow into you the more of those
four cardinal virtues that I spoke about
that you begin to practice the it pushes
out the rest of the stuff because
there's no room in there for the ego and
for all the false self in every moment
of your life as you leave here today
you have this choice
you can either be a host
to God or a hostage
to Your Ego it's your call spirituality
is that it's taking your attention off
of yourself it's to go back to the place
from which you originated and to live
from that which means it's about serving
it's about offering the fade is kind to
the kind and kind to the unkind
because the nature of his being
is kindness let go of everything that
you have do less and accomplish more so
you're changing from not trusting in
your nature to trusting in your nature
you change your thought from I need more
to What I Call Living contentment
what is this thing about more it's the
it's the Mantra of the ego isn't it I
have to have more I have to collect more
stuff I have to have more friends I have
to have more money it's more and more
more and more and more when where you
came from came from nowhere
you don't need anything it's a
continuous bombardment that we are all
exposed to in this whole world of
believing that we have to have more I
think that's true nobility really isn't
about being better than anyone else it's
about being better than you used to be
your highest self is uh is the part of
you that recognizes that within each and
every one of us is this this Divine
Essence it's invisible it's it's
worthless it's deathless it's changeless
and so I don't I literally don't take
any credit for it I just try to stay as
aligned as I possibly can with this
source of being that allows everything
to come into the world of of the
physical we have a tendency to evaluate
ourselves on the basis of our senses
you know so we have these uh these these
searchlights that we lose five of them
you know there's what we hear what we
see what we touch what we smell these
are our uh you know our senses and we
think that everything that our senses
are revealed to us is our reality but in
fact it's just a tiny little smidgen of
our reality the the our true Essence is
beyond our senses we have come to
believe in our limitations we've come to
believe in our ordinariness we've come
to believe that who we are is not God is
Not divine
all right so in order to transcend that
mentality you have to sort of reprogram
your subconscious mind
your subconscious mind is the mind that
is doing virtually everything that you
do the same intelligence that is that
created this infinite universe that
never ends is you you manifested in this
infinite Divine organizing intelligence
you're a part of all of it coming to
know God
it's not about discovering something
that resides outside of you
it's about remembering what's inside of
you
and living from that place
all of man's troubles
stem from his inability to sit quietly
in a room alone
if you could learn how to just make
peace with this inner part of you don't
put boundaries on me don't tell me what
I can do and what I can't do don't tell
me how to be there don't tell me what to
wear what to think don't tell me how to
even how to do yoga don't tell me I
don't want to be told
this is the soul speaking always the
soul is constantly having a desire to
expand and grow and anything or anyone
that comes into your life that attempts
to do that you will find yourself
fighting it it's only one in a million
people
who spend any amount of their time
giving thanks to the I am presence that
is your very essence your being
not giving thanks for all of the bounty
that you have in your life and for your
health and for all of the nice things
but to be in a state of gratitude for
the awareness that Who You Are
is this Divine Essence this Divine being
tonight and every night for the rest of
your life I want you to take the last
five minutes before you go off to sleep
and realize that you are about to
program your subconscious mind
all right your subconscious mind is most
at home when you are unconscious when
you are asleep
if you spend the last five minutes of
your day which so many people do
reviewing all of the things that you
don't like and all the things that
didn't work out and how terrible you
feel and who abused you and who was mean
to you and who said this and they did
this and you're constantly doing this
kind of thing with your mind
then you are programming your
subconscious mind that when you awaken
because you're now about to marinate for
the next eight hours in your
subconscious mind
and then when you awaken you will rejoin
the universal
subconscious mind the mind of God from
which we all originate we're all just
individualized Personal Expressions of
that one thing that we call the Dao or
God or Divine mind or Soul or Spirit but
the doubt that can be named is not the
Tao
so you want to be real careful about how
you program your subconscious mind what
you place into your subconscious mind as
you are about to go into this deep
slumber
is all dependent upon what you do the
last three or four or five minutes
before you go off to sleep you want to
place into your imagination whatever you
have placed into the I am that that I
spoke about earlier I am well I am
content I am peaceful I am happy I am
prosperous I am abundant I am God
I am God
I am God because at the basic core each
and every one of us are just that
foreign